how do you manage to apply discipline on
yourself rather than just do what you
like
you know uh
discipline is really overrated
discipline is just you fighting with
yourself to do something you don't want
to do so i would say it's more important
to find something that you want to do
and that can be productive
as opposed to
trying to discipline yourself
self-discipline is is uh
it's it's tough you won't sustain it uh
like you know tiger woods didn't become
a great golfer through self-discipline
now there are some things that you know
i'm not a very athletic person
so uh it's hard for me to do workouts on
a regular basis that i enjoy it took me
a long time to find one that i did enjoy
and now i like yoga because it's also
extremely meditative
and it's very relaxing
and it's it's kind of a trip to build up
your flexibility it makes you feel
younger so i've gotten into yoga so it's
the first time i would say i found some
athletic activity that i like to do for
fun
[Music]
do
[Music]
you